four-twenty is needed to you know you
need to keep your mind calm a lot of
people panicking and I can I can I can
help you acquire this virus or 20 show
addition let's do it I'm here with the
one the only the fabulous the
sensational the one voice only wonder
jailer kids what's up player what's up
bike was good brother which was been
going on you listen I see styling the
bootcamp [ __ ] the celebrity bootcamp
mention that does you see what kind of
[ __ ] love makes you do crazy I'm still
breathing my family happy my friends are
happy society yeah exactly
420 is needed to you know you need to
need to keep your mind calm a lot of
people panicking and I can I can I can
help you acquire this virus or whatever
they got going around you gotta keep
your energy right your nerves gonna be
right up stay calm
how's the music industry adapting with
no live performances you gotta be tired
yeah doing everything the same way we
doing this interview everything is that
everything is from the crib real you
know satellite alive and zooming things
like that they coming up with some
performances though I got a few offers
to do some performances from the crib so
I guess they figuring out ways with all
this new technology they won't they
gonna try to work it out
listen you saw the light the night sky
so he can do that stuff to you so sure
got a whole bunch of like the purpose of
communicate is phenomenal really
unbelievable we think about it and he
said definitely I think you know there's
a test it's a test that bring people
closer together bring people closer to
their families you know I mean it just
make you away take things for granted as
little as fresh air okay I gotta do
something to the public but something
new I've maybe been awakened [ __ ] my
oh you know I was going to a few things
I lost I lost one of our good partners
from colon cancer so that's what caused
me to even drop the album I named it
after him it's government name is
Ignatians the firing was the name of it
it Nations Ignatius yeah Ignatius would
be our one is it out tater he's out
right now you listen going this
quarantine thing is some good music to
listen to family can listen to it could
work out to it you can zoom out - it's a
good body of work for people to listen
to why they stuck in the house right now
you know like to look up another we got
a new locks album actually that we
release in April we'll probably have to
get pushed back - man chill down but
yeah we let out a single last Friday
called loyalty and love check that out
and learn me too with your guys this us
me on album we got BMX we got up got
some dope features on the album P and B
rock BMX so fire features but or lawyer
to your love disabled is just us and so
then I throw you on Pat tools and J and
Jim jump I was looking at on my youtube
today no doubt no doubt how he staying
fit [ __ ] what you doing man
walking the stairs of the grip pushup
look around the community ride the bike
around the community I'm actually about
the bike treadmill baby tomorrow so
today agenda dig listen ain't it I'm
stem research right and I'm giving me
next time you see me right if you don't
see me within the next 30 days you'll
see me with the 30 day no doubt no doubt
you already look like come you mean
nobody may put the whole stem research
that's dope
you know we got the juice bars over here
also juices for life alone without for
storage one in Brooklyn two in the
garage
how about that see that breathing really
with the it is doing actually great
especially in these times everybody just
feel the need they've got they running
in for the ginger and lime shots vitamin
C shots the green drapes very health
conscious definitely you know just try
to keep my people alive we all got
families suffer from cancer and diabetes
and things like that so we just try to
make a healthy choice within all of them
fast food choices that they put in our
neighborhood just try to put some juice
bars in between there to give our people
another could I help you out I look at
it this is cool I lost around 70 pounds
eighty pounds in the last year that's
great workout I can't believe that 53
right I feel better than I did at 23
look great you look thank you thank you
medicine
works all the stuff that they have and
no listen I'm going to do this show
where I'm going all over the world and
try to ancient medicine you know like
the total is snake smoker and you know
and you see what effect the ancient
medicine hundreds of thousands maybe
millions using animals and plants to get
well so I'm gonna I'm going to do a show
traveling all over the world I'm using
all of the ancient medicine in the world
that's that's fine that's gonna be fire
you got featured me or to have this old
ago so we try something a little bit of
smoke big man listen man they got stuff
that they never tell you about things
that make your heart or thing to make
your muscles baby make you think a
little listen trust me man they think I
had the word on that the government
doesn't want us to know about this
almost like it's magic man it's just
makeup yeah keep me in the loop you
already know but when he would come to
the hyperbole care longest epidemic
stuff I'm I want you to come to Houston
and try some of this movie or turn this
medicine definitely shoulder this thing
is over I'm coming the scene you know
that we look forward to that and bring
style in those guys what you made
loot and they're still hanging bring the
whole camp you know that we coming back
yeah for real man you be good and give
my best to the family thank you
appreciate you might be safe